so I'm confused about this I'm sorry I
just have to ask so one thing a director
does not want in their movie is acting
it doesn't yes I have said this and
maybe it upsets some people along with
one of the most dangerous things on the
set is an actor with a plan but I also
say what we don't want in our movie is
acting but by acting acting
I mean pretending a manufactured
performance no it's true there are
actors who have won Academy Awards for
what I call acting because he Cannes
it's also well crafted and presented and
considered and worked out I think what
we really want to see what I want to see
I'm not going to be startled by a
brilliant quote performance I'm gonna be
startled by an extraordinary human being
who reveals themselves authentically on
the screen when I see something that I
wasn't expecting what I feel generally
is coming genuinely from that character
that was not planned that was not
considered that was not honed sharply it
was just came out that's what I wanted
and that's why I see him like in blue
jasmine or a Manchester by the sea I see
moments like that that I just find
chilling that's what I want no I've seen
a lot of performers that are very
manufactured now there are some films
and some film makers where that kind of
acting is what's required
you watch Wes Anderson's work and stuff
like that
that's what's required that's his style
nothing wrong with that that's the style
of that work you could even go back to
Kabuki theater that's a style what I'm
saying because what I want when I see a
movie as I want to feel I'm in the
presence of these huge genuine human
beings and experiencing them deeply and
profoundly and then it's not pretense
it's not calculated it's genuine
so no acting please which means you have
to stop directing directors have to stop
directing so actors will stop acting
which mean that's why it's directors
switch to interrogation and form a
relationship with the character rather
than the director telling the actor
here's what I want you to do the
director stimulating the character to go
in and find what they do do ok so
instead of Casey Affleck's character and
Manchester by the sea if I'm his
director saying you know what Casey I
want you to look really depressed and I
want you to be in this room with no
furniture and instead I'm going up to
him and I'm saying your life it's
falling apart and you're here alone in
this dingy room yes I've been saying to
his character I've forgotten the
character's name but saying to Casey as
his character you're alone in this did
you what what the hell are you gonna do
what the hell are you gonna do do you
realize but everybody back at Manchester
by the sea hates you do you realize that
and you're gonna go back there why what
are you thinking now I'm getting him
into the into the chaos of the character
then I say ok let's do the scene now we
doing the scene now he's totally in the
chaos of the character and trying to
fight through that chaos while he's
trying to fight his way through a scene
simultaneously sort of like we all do in
life every day we fight through our own
chaos while we're trying to get through
the daily chaos he's not thinking about
acting he's thinking about survival
seriously how do I get through this how
do I get through this moment how do I
quiet the voices in my head that came
through the interrogation the voices are
going mad in his head and he's trying to
quiet those down or sort through those
while he's trying to deal with whoever
this lady who needs some plumbing done
or whatever it is and he's that's what
he's dealing with he's dealing with only
what the character is dealing with not
with what Casey Affleck is dealing with
Casey Affleck at that moment does not
matter
and quite honestly I can tell you as a
director at that moment if I was
directing them I don't care what Casey
Affleck this thinking I don't care what
he's thinking about the character I
don't want him thinking about the
character I only care about the
character I'm there to film the
character not to film an acting
performance it's a fine line but it's a
significant line
you